[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
kelly clarkson is so not moving on after
anne hathaway beats her at her own game
i call cheating
during a visit to the kelly clarkson
show anne agrees to a friendly singing
competition game so we thought we would
make things a little intense here too
because i love competition and so we're
gonna have a competition and it's called
sing that name that tune but anne
quickly puts kelly to shame when the
american idol winner fails to recognize
one of her biggest songs ever i was like
and adding insult to injury it happens
just after kelly says this can you play
a freaking song jason
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah kelly totally faced plants as ann
catches on to the song's instantly
recognizable chorus
how did you know it from jack that
kelly clarkson if you do not understand
how much we all love that i watched
everybody
the first one
everybody here knew it a moment like
this well it leaves the talk show host
stunned and at a loss for words this is
embarrassing kelly's hit since you've
been gone became an instant anthem when
it hit the radio in 2004 and at the time
a 22 year old kelly told et what went
into writing this classic it's basically
just kind of a rock song and it's
a pop rock song obviously and um it's
just about a relationship that went sour
and i thought everything was good and it
and it wasn't so you know so you're like
okay well whatever and then you move on
and you're like well since you've been
gone i'm doing better anyway so it's
kind of that kind of song so i kind of
have this thing with girl anthems like
this independence
i kind of have this thing going on but i
don't know it just fits me at this point
in my life so autobiographical at all
yeah pretty much
yep what a surprise yeah well any 22
year old girl goes through that crap so
there you go we'll give kelly a pass
though girl is booked and busy on top of
hosting her daytime show and coaching on
the voice kelly is now sharing mc duties
with snoop dogg on nbc's newest singing
series american song contest all that
music from across america will go head
to head on one stand
[Applause]
every state and territory will compete
live for your votes in the biggest
televised music event you've ever seen
america's next great hit could come from
your hometown it's based on the
long-running eurovision contest overseas
but instead of singer-songwriters from
different countries battling it out for
top honors it's a state verse state
battle we've got 56 songs one rapping
each state in territory plus washington
dc y'all it is state versus state and in
the end only one song will bring home
the win here's why kelly says she simply
couldn't pass up the gig well i think
most people know me as more of a
vocalist but i'm also a songwriter so it
was really cool i loved eurovision i
actually found out about it like 20
years ago when i first started going
overseas and i thought it was an amazing
concept and how it was
how it came to fruition was cool but i i
love that it's about the song and songs
are so important i feel like sometimes
we lose sight of that like with with
records and sometimes we just go for
something quick and easy and and this is
about a song like really moving you and
touching you and if it's happy sad fun
whatever it is
[Music]